there are over 7 billion people across
the globe in Europe there's a population
of 742 million people living in 216
million households ultra-fast broadband
has a huge positive impact on quality of
life but do you know how many European
households actually are
fiber-to-the-home subscribers less than
one in 10 homes have fibre to the home
here are some success stories
others are not so fortunate but they are
keen to have fiber here are a few
testimonials
yeah yes we a letter e rising ecology
text cadiz beautiful grass ogre the walk
will go to the store and investor my
poster block heater model reversible
musa yar'adua future is a toccata
p.pur.aqua together good morning my name
is Phillip I'm a high-tech farmer and I
want to use state-of-the-art technology
to increase productivity that's why I
want five lapel Toma she wrote a
compositor air tonight nepeta Jima
musica como te SE pasa que Ella FIBA
hello my name is Pierre get he leave a
filmer of allied I keep this in mind
climbed off can t know this heavily
glass father
join the call of fiber
you